let's talk about hatred mail if you have
never heard of hatred mail before this
is what hatred mail is because the
government that is supposedly totally
Anette right the same government that
can pull off a conspiracy that will blow
your mind
hatred mail written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman but because America and
because freedom all right every once in
a while the hatreds come from the
anti-vaxxer community that is indeed the
subject of this week's hatred mail let's
listen together
tell me something David Pakman were you
born a vacuous self-righteous [ __ ] I
can't believe you support this David
very disappointed I know eight people in
Ethiopia who contracted the polio virus
through the vaccine if you believe in
your vaccine so much why are you scared
of those who are not vaccinated
shouldn't your vaccine protect you from
the unvaccinated I dare you to vaccinate
my kids you'll be met with my husband's
fist in your face morons quite a threat
issue there well listen I am NOT a
medical professional so I would not go
around trying to vaccinate anybody but
clearly someone who doesn't understand
the concepts of herd immunity someone
who doesn't understand the concept of no
vaccine is 100% but when you have more
of the population vaccinated than less
of the population vaccinated you are
protecting everybody both those who
cannot be vaccinated and everybody who
does have the vaccination are you
shocked Pat that this anti-vaxxer seem
to be missing some basic understanding
of how vaccination works well it is
hatred Mel after all and the other thing
is this is so one-dimensional - I mean I
understand that you know as someone who
has a ton of vaccine under my belt I'm
unlikely to get these diseases but I
also care about your kids not getting
vaccinated themselves no doubt about it
and if you want to turn hatred mail into
something positive you can do it with
the coupon code hey tree at 40 okay if
you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you can put in the
Vonn code h80 our IOT 4-0 and it'll save
you 40% off of your membership which is
it's kind of like a big middle finger to
the hatreds every time people use that
coupon code and if you don't you get
punched apparently by this woman yeah
that's exactly who would be doing